What can I do to help with high cholesterol? My doctor wants me to go on statins
so
So it's better than what you what you define high cholesterol
So when I graduated from school
220 and above
I think it was 220 and above was considered high then they dropped it out to 200 and above was considered high
Now I think it's eight 180 and above was considered high. Why?
Because they can sell more statins I'm sorry, but that sounds really neat, but it's true
So that's the reason why they do it high cholesterol by itself is not you know
We're gonna be arterial
Damaging it's when you have
When you have high cholesterol with damage or etched arteries that the arteries are gonna be complex with that cholesterol
Always with high cholesterol. You always want to find out why now there's some people with high cholesterol that have a
familial congenital condition of hyper cholesterol ebia that no matter what you do even taking statins
You're not gonna really get them even close to normal ranges
And there's some people with cholesterol over 300 that have had cholesterol over 300 that have no no familial
Condition of high cholesterol, and they you know, they're in their 60s or 70s and they've had this their whole life and
Have had
Scans of their heart and have no cholesterol
Well, what's the what's the deal with that because it's not high cholesterol alone that causes arterial sclerosis
It is high cholesterol with with it inflammatory condition tied to the endothelial cells, which are the cells that lie in the arteries
So endothelial condition is what is really causing the problems not the high cholesterol by itself
Now I have people with cholesterol of 225 and their doctor is putting heavy pressure on them to go on statins
Well, you need to educate yourself and fight back against that. I would not do that
But again, you don't just look at cholesterol. So again, you don't just look at one test
Plus you should break down the cholesterol
So if you're going to do a proper blood test for
inflammatory markers that are tied to fats and
Tied to in inflammation in the endothelial cells
You need to break down the cholesterol into the different densities of
LDLs and oxidized LDLs and you need to do a more comprehensive blood test before you start thinking about going on stats
I'm not against using medications when it's the right thing to do, but I've used I'm very against
Using medications just to alter a blood test because a person could have low cholesterol
Tell you my dad was a perfect example of that
He had low cholesterol and it had a heart attack had a triple bypass surgery
Well, that happened. He has low cholesterol because cholesterol is not the issue
You know, it's that is not the problem. It's inflammation of the
endocardial tissue
And the most common causes of endocardial
And endothelial inflammation is H. Pylori chronic Lyme
heavy metal toxicity
There's a couple other ones
But you got to dig into that and buy that source of that so
Very very important